let's say this is me right over here and
I'm drifting through space at a constant
velocity relative to any other inertial
frame of reference and so I am I am in
an inertial frame of reference myself
and in fact I'm going to define my frame
of reference by me I'm going to say I'm
at the origin of my frame of reference
so at all at all times
I consider myself to be stationary and
I'm at the point x equals 0 and we're
going to focus on just the X dimension
to simplify our discussion I have you
know my oxygen and everything so and
food so so no need no need to worry
about me
now what I've drawn here are some axes
so that I can plot I can plot the path
of things as time progresses in my frame
of reference and one thing that many of
you all might have noticed is that I
have plotted time in seconds on the
vertical axis and our position our X
position in meters on the horizontal
axis and that might be a little bit
counterintuitive for a lot of you all
especially with math backgrounds in fact
it's a little bit uncomfortable for me
we often prefer to put time on the
horizontal axis and position on the
vertical axis so this is a little bit
counterintuitive but this is you know
our choice is a little bit arbitrary in
in math class we like to think of our
independent variable on our horizontal
axis and we think of time is somehow
driving position so that's why we tend
to put time there that we position there
but you can you can flip them around and
as will get more more into physics we'll
see well maybe we shouldn't necessarily
think of time always the driving
position or maybe position in some ways
our driving time but we will we'll get
into that but let's just first feel get
a little bit comfortable with this so
what would be what would be my position
over time on this diagram right over
here and you might notice these numbers
one second two second three second and
then in meters have three times 10 to
the 8th 6 times 10 to the 8th 9 times 2
VA so these are massive massive numbers
and you could guess where they are
coming from they're coming from the
notion that the speed of light is
approximately 3 times 10 to the 8th
meters per second but we'll get that and
we'll get to that in a second but let's
to think about my position over time in
my frame of reference here so time
equals zero my exposition in this frame
of reference is zero I consider myself
to be stationary after one second well
my position is still zero after two
seconds my position is still x equals
zero after three seconds my position is
still x equals zero so my I guess you
could almost consider my path on this
diagram where I'm plotting time and
space and at least in the X Direction is
going to look like is going to look like
whoops I can do a better job than that
it's going to look it's going to look
like it's going to look like that that
would be my path on my little time and
space the axes are on on this little
diagram that I have but let's let's
let's think about something a little bit
more interesting let's think about me
having a flashlight so this is a
flashlight here and I at time equals
zero I turn on that flashlight exactly
at time equals zero I turn on that
flashlight and let's think about that
very first photon of light that emits
from my flashlight and let's plot its
path on my little diagram here so time
equals zero it's exactly where I am so
time equals zero its position is zero
meters but after one second where is my
photon of light and I'm going to put it
and I'm and the photon is moving in the
positive x direction so it's moving in
the positive x direction with a with a
velocity of c.c meters per second in the
positive x direction and so after one
second it will have moved three times
ten to the eighth meters after two
seconds it will have moved six times 10
to the eighth meters and I've
intentionally scaled my axes so that now
if I were to draw the the position of
light relative to time it's going to be
it's going to be at a 45 degree angle
and I that's just a artifact of how I
picked my pick my axes but let's see if
I can plot this so it's going to look
something like this and this is hand
drawn so it's not going to be perfect so
the position of that photon over time is
going to look like that after one second
after one second 3 times 10 to the 8th
meters after 2 seconds 6 times 10 to the
8th meters after 3 seconds we have 9
times 10 to the 8th meters all right
well that's that's that's reasonably
interesting so far we're getting a
little bit comfortable with my little
diagram here where maybe some of us are
getting a little bit more comfortable
with time on the vertical axis and and
my position on the horizontal axis but
now let's introduce another character
another character who could almost
define there or who could define their
own frame of reference so let's say that
right at time equals zero a spaceship
passes me by so that's I can draw a
bigger spaceship than that so there you
go that's that's the spaceship and in
the spaceship I have my friend so that's
that's that's the spaceship and the
spaceship is traveling with a pretty
incredible velocity in the positive
x-direction so I guess if this is if
this is the specter is is the speed of
light which seems like an awfully short
arrow but if I'm going to say that's the
speed of light then let's say that this
thing is moving with half the speed of
light which is still incredibly fast so
the velocity the magnitude of the
velocity here is 0.5 C so let's plot and
and my friend is stationary in that
spaceship the spaceship is moving at
this constant velocity 0.5 C in the
positive x direction so they also are in
an inertial frame of reference because
it's a it's at a constant velocity
relative to me which is in an inertial
frame of reference and so let's plot my
let's plot her let's plot her position
on my little diagram so time equals zero
she's exactly where I am she's she's
she's at the origin of my frame of
reference her X her X position is zero
now after one second she's moving half
the speed of light so after one second
she would have gone 1.5 times 10 to the
eighth meters per second so she
would have gone about that far after two
seconds she would have gone as far as
light would go in one second she's going
half the speed of light so she would go
about that far after three seconds she
will have gone 4.5 times 10 to the 8th
meters so let me put that right over
there and you see where this is going so
if I were to plot her path if I were to
plot her path it would look like it
would look like this it would look like
this path of my friend that's the path
of my friend right over there and I want
you to just kind of think about this
think about this a little bit think
about how these different lines are what
they represent once again get familiar
with the T on the vertical axis but now
in the next video we're going to use
this what I just drew to draw her frame
of reference to draw a coordinate system
or or I guess you could say a space-time
diagram for her frame of reference on
top of this one and at least in the
context of this video in the next few
videos we're going to assume a Newtonian
world we're not going to get to Einstein
in special relativity we're just going
to assume well we'll get to that in the
next video